ABOUT OUR ENVIRONMENT.
THAT'S AHEAD.
>>> BUT WE BEGIN THIS CAME HOUR
WITH A LOGISTICAL NIGHTMARE.
MORE THAN 10% OF THE WORLD'S
TRAVEL THROUGH THE SUEZ CANAL
BUT SINCE TUESDAY IT'S BEEN
COMPLETELY BLOCKED AFTER A HUGE
CARGO SHIP RAN AGROUND.
WHILE THERE'S HOPE IT COULD BE
FREED SOMETIME THIS WEEKEND, CBS
NEWS CORRESPONDENT LUCY CRAFT,
LIZ BEAT PALMER REPORT FROM
TOKYO, TEL AVIV AND CAPE TOWN TO
EXPLAIN HOW ONE VESSEL'S MISHAP
CAN AFFECT ALL OF OUR LIVES.
>> Reporter: GOOD MORNING.
THE SUEZ CANAL SHUT DOWN HAS
PLAYED HAVOC WITH A MAJOR TRADE
ROUTE CONNECTING EAST AND WEST.
WHETHER SEMICONDUCTORS AND
SMARTPHONES EXPORTED FROM
SOUTHEAST CHINA, FOOTWEAR AND
APPAREL MADE IN INDIA,
AUTOMOBILES FROM ASIAN FAKE
STORIES AND ION BATTERIES ALL
RELY ON THE SUEZ CANAL.
ALSO THE PREFERRED ROUTE FOR
ASIA'S IMPORTS OF CRUDE OIL AND
NATURAL GAS FROM THE MIDDLE EAST
AND RUSSIA.
19,000 VESSELS PASSED THROUGH
THE CANAL IN 2019.
THAT'S AN AVERAGE OF 50 SHIPS
EACH DAY.
BEHIND ME IS THE MEDITERRANEAN
SEA.
NORMALLY BUSY NORTHERN GATEWAY.
RIGHT NOW SHIPPING IS AT A
STANDSTILL.
200 VESSELS ARE WAITING AT BOTH
ENDS OF THE CANAL.
BUT SHE REMAINS STUCK, SALVAGE
CREWS HAVE BEEN WORKING AROUND
THE CLOCK, AT THE MOMENT
CONCENTRATING OF DIGGING TONS OF
SAND OUT FROM UNDER THE SHIP'S
B
BOW AND STERN.
THE HOPE A HIGH TIDE WILL LIFT
IT.
THE UNITED STATES HAS OFFERED TO
HELP THE EGYPTIANS FREE THE
VESSEL BUT UNTIL THAT HAPPENS
SHIPS TRAVELING BETWEEN ASIA AND
THE WEST WILL HAVE TO TAKE THE
LONG WAY AROUND THE CONTINENT OF
AFRICA, 4,000 EXTRA MILES.
THE DETOUR AROUND THE AFRICA
CAPE IS COSTLY AND RISKY ADDING
UP TO TWO WEEKS TO JOURNEY.
THAT'S IN ADDITION TO THE
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
IN EXTRA FUEL COSTS.
BUT AS SHIPPING COMPANIES
CONTEMPLATE HOW TO BYPASS THIS
INCREASING EXTENSIVE TRAFFIC JAM
THEY HAVE TO WAY OUT THE
SECURITY CONCERNS.
PIRATES HAVE LONG PREYED ON
SHIPS AT THE HORN OF AFRICA BUT
NOW THE SEAS OF AFRICA ARE
CONSIDERED TO BE THE WORLD'S
MOST PERILOUS.
THERE'S BEEN A SURGE IN
KIDNAPPINGS IN GULF OF GUINEA.
THERE'S AN ENVIRONMENTAL COST.
SHIPS CIRCUMVENTING AFRICA WILL
EMIT MORE GREENHOUSE GAS INTO
AFRICA.
>> IN THIS DAY AND AGE IT'S SO
HARD TO BELIEVE A SHIP LIKE THAT
CAN GET STUCK AND DIFFICULT TO
GET IT OUT.
>> DID YOU SEE THE SIZE OF THAT
PUPPY?
HUGE.
>> CAN'T GET OUT WITH A TINY
LITTLE BACKHOE.
COME ON.
>> I LOVE LIZ PALMER, YEAH